foreign
warships unclogging coordinates
hello and welcome to a new episode of RT
Essentials I'm Mark Ellis it's time to
talk about sci-fi and while we are very
aware of the countless amazing movies
that fall under this wonderful genre and
we do love to celebrate those today
we're talking about science fiction
television or TV for short there are
some obvious Classics that have paved
the way for bigger and better series
throughout the decades all of which
we're going to cover and as budgets and
expectations have grown exponentially
especially with the rise of streaming
Wars the past few years great Sci-Fi TV
offerings ain't gonna slow down anytime
soon so please come aboard the ship and
strap yourself fit they say that in a
lot of Sci-Fi TV shows because we're
headed to the vast world of the best
science fiction television of all time
stranger things
[Applause]
and starting things off as one of the
most popular sci-fi shows of the past
five years stranger things the series
was created by Matt and Ross Duffer
professionally known as The Duffer
brothers who also serve as showrunners
and executive producers the series is
set in the 1980s in the fictional town
of Hawkins Indiana and centers around
numerous Supernatural events occurring
around the town events that are
connected to a hostile alternate reality
called the upside down series stars
include Winona Ryder David Harbor Millie
Bobby Brown Gayton Matarazzo and Finn
wolfhard who recorded his audition tape
from his bed because he was sick before
working on the series The Duffer
brothers were mentored by M Night
Shyamalan while writing for Wayward
Pines which Shyamalan executive produced
and when it came to this series The
Duffer brothers were looking to develop
a series with a mix of investigative
drama and Supernatural elements along
with horror science fiction and
childlike sensibilities I think they
succeeded
while shopping for a network The Duffer
Brothers prepared a 20-page pitch book
to go along with the script that would
essentially be similar to the series
first episode at one point during
development the setting was Montauk New
York and nearby Long Island and the
title was originally known as Montage
the dubbers have also infused plenty of
1980s pop culture references in the
series inspired by The Works of Steven
Spielberg John Carpenter and Stephen
King in fact the Hawkins police vehicles
and uniforms are identical to those used
in Jaws and Jaws too stranger things has
garnered dozens of Emmy nominations and
plenty of wins to go along with a
die-hard and dedicated fan base the
series has spawned books video games
Theme Park attractions toys and comic
books with four critically acclaimed
Seasons already under its belt the
series was renewed for a fifth and final
season hopefully coming soon
Star Trek the Next Generation on screen
Captain jean look
at seven zero one D you will lower your
Shields and prepare to transport
yourself aboard our vessel boldly going
to the next spot on this list is Star
Trek the Next Generation this was the
first live-action spin-off from the
1960s cult classic TV show and aired
from September of 1987 to May of 1994
spanning 178 episodes over seven seasons
the series was created by Gene
Roddenberry who also created the
original and was set a century after the
events of that show next Generation
featured a new crew with Patrick Stewart
leading the way as Captain Jean-Luc
Picard plus there is a new starship
Enterprise the
ncc-1701-d for all you Trekkers keeping
score out there and trekkies don't want
to leave anybody out in this segment
after the original series gained and
kept more popularity following its
original Three season run Ron Berry
responded with a short-lived Animated
Series in the mid-1970s with the
original cast returning before moving
into making movies with them by 1979. by
the mid 80s Roddenberry became less
involved with the films and shifted his
Focus to a new series in the franchise
after failing to land a full series
commitment from a major Network next
generation was released straight to
syndication instead a strategy that I'd
say paid off Klingon warships armed and
ready sir
what should it be Tomah
survive our assault
you will not survive ours
shall we die together the series became
very popular and was a hit with critics
right away their Premiere was the first
TV episode to be nominated for a Hugo
award honorary great science fiction
Works since 1972 and the first season
received Emmy nominations for six
different episodes the series had
reached nearly 12 million viewers a week
by its fifth season with a series finale
being watched by over 30 million viewers
two years later the success led to
another new series Star Trek Deep Space
Nine released in 1993. plus the Next
Generation characters have since
returned in four films over the years
and the spin-off series Star Trek Picard
in 2020. Star Trek the Next Generation
with five of Seven Seasons coming in
hovering around a hundred percent fresh
on the Tomato Meter also spawned
numerous novels comic books and video
games and after ending its run with 19
Emmys two Hugo Awards five Saturn Awards
and a Peabody Award I would say job well
done
Doctor Who it's like a special effect
boy Matchstick man
[Music]
compensating we're not sure who's on
first or if what's on second but we do
know that the next Sci-Fi series on this
here list is Doctor Who the series
originally ran from 1963 to 1989 and
after a failed TV movie reboot in 1996
an updated continuation of the series
launched in 2005 and is still going
strong the series follows the adventures
of a Time Lord who they called the
doctor an extraterrestrial being who
appeared to be human the doctor rides
around the universe in a time traveling
spaceship called the Tardis and with the
help of various friends helps out people
takes on bad guys and saves
civilizations just another day's work
there's been over a dozen doctors during
its run and that transition from one
lead actor to another is written into
the show with the concept of
regeneration into a new Incarnation it's
delusional
calculations alone would take hundreds
of years oh hundreds and hundreds but
don't worry I started a very long time
ago
morning of all Council of gallery three
this is the doctor you might say I've
been doing this all my lives this plot
device means that a Time Ward will
transform into a new body when their
current one is too badly harmed in 2017
Jody Whitaker became the first woman and
the 13th person to headline the series
as the doctor and it was announced in
2022 that shooty gotwa would be the 14th
incarnation of the doctor becoming the
first black actor to lead the series
Hugh Grant was once approached to play
the doctor but he turned down the role
because he wasn't sure if the newer
version of the series would take off
dude come on babe Doctor Who is a
significant part of British pop culture
and has gained a cult following all over
the world it's launched numerous
spin-offs in the form of comic books
novels audio dramas films and a few
different series Doctor Who has also
made it into the Guinness World Records
as the longest running sci-fi television
show in the world and also as the most
successful science fiction series ever
judging by overall broadcast ratings
book and DVD sales and iTunes traffic
the Mandalorian
foreign
coming out of light speed to be the next
series on this list is the Mandalorian
this space western series was created by
John Favreau who'd already become a
major force behind the camera for Disney
and marble and premiered with the launch
of the Disney plus streaming service in
November of 2019. this marks the first
live-action Series in the Star Wars
franchise picking up five years after
the events of Return of the Jedi Pedro
Pascal stars as the titular character a
one bouncy Hunter who ends up going on
the run in the first season to protect
what is known as the child AKA grogu AKA
baby Yoda
foreign
[Music]
a big part of the success of the
Mandalorian is due to the technology
that Favreau has taken advantage of
specifically something called stagecraft
which consists of large LED video
screens with digital environments being
rendered in real time for actors to
perform in front of instead of just
pretending in front of a green screen
the series has also been loaded with
great directors after years behind the
scenes for a number of Star Wars
animated series executive producer Dave
polony directed the series's first
episode making his live-action
directorial debut and other directors
who have worked on the show include Rick
vamiyua Deborah Chow Robert Rodriguez
Bryce Dallas Howard and taika watiti
among others that's a pretty good list
plus Carl Weathers who plays grief karga
in the series has also stepped behind
the camera the series also featured the
first live-action appearances of Ahsoka
Tano and Bo Katan from the various Star
Wars animated series and has featured
other characters from previous Star Wars
media including spoiler alert Luke
Skywalker and Boba Fett with Boba and
Ahsoka getting their own spin-off series
The Mandalorian was nominated for a
bunch of Primetime Emmy Awards
throughout its first two seasons
including Outstanding Drama Series and
is at least two more seasons on the way
they expanse
plot a gravity assist trajectory down to
Ganymede no engine just thrusters
[Music]
I won't say it was going to be easy
all right darling
Saddle Up
slingshot time expanding to the next
spot on this list of the best Sci-Fi TV
of all time is the expanse this show is
based on a series of novels of the same
name by James essay Corey which is
actually a pen name for authors Daniel
Abraham and Ty Frank who also serve as
writers and producers and every season
finale Bears the title of the book
adapted during that season the series
has set hundreds of years in the future
where Humanity has colonized the solar
system and Mars has become an
independent military power as a group of
humans unravel a massive plot that
threatens the Solar System's fragile
state of Peace the pilot episode for the
expanse was screened at Comic-Con in
July of 2015 before launching on the
Sci-Fi Network in November after three
seasons sci-fi canceled the series in
May of 2018 but fans and celebrities
alike protested the cancellation until
Amazon picked it up for three more
seasons guys
what the hell just happened the novel
just messed
how the hell did it change course
what
it's in the voodoo didn't move
[Music]
Arab State as with many sci-fi shows the
main spaceship views becomes an
important character in its own right and
that's no different here the name of the
ship in this series rossinante is also
the name of Don Quixote's Horrors from
the novel Don Quixote and also the name
of a spaceship and a song by the band
Rush rock and roll baby during its run
the expanse received a Hugo Award for
best dramatic presentation and three
Saturn Award nominations for Best
science fiction series and it was
nominated for People's Choice Award for
best sci-fi fantasy show of 2018 but it
lost to Winona Earp along with being a
huge hit with fans all six seasons are
coming in Very Fresh on the Tomato Meter
with a critics consensus that says the
expanse Blends sci-fi elements and
detective Noir into a visually
compelling hole
Battlestar Galactica altitude 99 000
falling Like a Rock watch them all and
buy fdm
[Music]
fighting its way into the next spot on
this list is the series Battlestar
Galactica this is a reimagining of the
1970s TV show and was created by Ronald
D Moore who worked previously on three
different Star Trek series and would go
on to create the Sci-Fi series Outlander
the show follows Humanity's war with the
Android race known as the cylons and
Bucks the trend of The Originals spin on
Star Wars in favor of a darker tone and
seriously heady twist that strongly
resonated with more modern audiences the
cast was led by Edward James almost and
included people like Trisha Helfer Grace
Park and Katie Sackhoff the latter of
whom played Starbuck who was a man in
the original then there's Richard Hatch
who played Tom zarick in the new series
and Captain Apollo in the original and
he's the only actor to appear in both
Basics launching missiles 40. correction
50 plus inbound half targeted on us half
on the fleet have Triple A Target only
missiles going towards a fleet we can
handle the hits they can't the original
series was canceled after just 24
episodes in 1979 and then brought back
for 10 episodes in 1980 after a write-in
campaign remember writing letters it
used to work the franchise then grew in
the form of novels comic books a board
game and video games before another
crack in the series was attempted in the
early 2000s the pilot for this
reimagined version First ran as a
two-part three-hour mini-series in
December of 2003 leading to four regular
seasons that aired on sci-fi before
wrapping up in May of 2009. it was
followed by a prequel spin-off series
that aired for one season in 2010 and a
spin-off web series that later aired us
a TV movie on sci-fi in 2013. during its
sixth season run Battlestar Galactica
earned a Peabody Award and the
television critics association's Award
for program of the year to go along with
19 Emmy nominations and three wins plus
it was named as one of Time magazine's
100 best TV shows of all time in 2006.
The X-Files Mulder in these files
I found references to experiments that
were conducted here in the U.S by Axis
power scientists who were given amnesty
experiments some kind of tests on humans
but they refer to as merchandise
foreign
mysteriously arriving next on this list
is the X-Files the series was created by
Chris Carter and revolves around FBI
special agents motor and Scully played
by David Duchovny and Jillian Anderson
respectively to investigate unsolved
cases involving paranormal phenomenon
known as drum roll please The X-Files
the original series aired from 1993 to
2002 on Fox and then returned with a six
episode 10th season in early 2016
followed by a 10 episode 11th season in
2018. Fox Executives rejected Chris
Carter's first pitch for the series but
eventually hired him to do the pilot on
which Carter worked with NYPD Blue
producer Daniel sakon The X-Files was
inspired by and contains elements from
such series as the Twilight Zone Twin
Peaks and especially Cold Track The
Night Stalker from the 1970s it also
Drew stylistic inspiration from the
documentary The Thin Blue Line and the
British TV series Prime Suspect
[Music]
[Music]
filming for the series took place in
Vancouver for the first five seasons but
eventually as most series do move to Los
Angeles to accommodate David Duchovny
schedule and speaking of which Duchovny
was actually looking to focus on feature
films at the time this show was casting
but he and his manager liked the script
enough that he ended up auditioning and
getting the part and Duchovny along with
Jillian Anderson both starred in two
spin-off films as well 1998's the
X-Files as part of the series continuity
and the Standalone X-Files I want to
believe in 2008. the franchise also
includes the spin-off series Millennium
which ran for three seasons on Fox from
1996 to 1999 and the lone gunman which
ran for one season in 2001 and was also
created by Chris Carter alongside some
guy named Vince Gilligan and among the
60 plus Emmy nominations and 16 wins for
the X-Files was Jillian Anderson winning
for outstanding lead actress to go along
along with two best actress SAG Awards
as well
point is she's good at action
lost when did you come here how long ago
60 65 days what was the date September
22nd
it was September 22nd
[Music]
I think I crashed you a thing finding
its way to the next spot on this list
are the best Sci-Fi TV of all time is
the series Lost with the Tom Hanks film
Castaway serving as inspiration lost was
created by JJ Abrams Jeffrey Lieber and
Damon Lindelof who together wrote the
pilot episode and had JJ directed the
series was sci-fi and Supernatural
elements mixed in follows the survivors
of a commercial airplane that crashes on
a strange and unknown Island somewhere
in the South Pacific we think it aired
on ABC from September 2004 to May of
2010 lasting six seasons and 121
episodes leading a large ensemble cast
with Matthew Fox who played Jack his
character was originally supposed to die
in the pilot and be played by Michael
Keaton really I love that guy but execs
were digging Jack and wanted him to
stick around so Fox got the gig but
because of that huge cast not to mention
the expense of filming on location in
Oahu this was one of the most expensive
shows on TV there was a 14 million
dollar price tag on on the two-part
pilot episode alone the most expensive
in ABC's history at the time
[Music]
someone come
[Applause]
they're dead
it killed them
it killed them all
turns out it was worth all that dough
with the first season averaging 16
million viewers per episode and that was
a common theme throughout its run with
the sixth and final season still pulling
in 11 million folks a week among the
many accolades earned over the six fresh
seasons of loss was two of the big ones
and Emmy for Outstanding Drama and a
Screen Actors Guild award for
outstanding Ensemble into drama plus the
show's cult-like fan base fans worldwide
and is still going strong known to
gather at conventions and create all
kinds of fan sites and pages and while
the series finale was very polarizing
among fans and critics it is still
considered by many in both of those
groups to be among the greatest TV
series of all time
The Twilight Zone you're a bad man
you're a very bad man and you keep
[Music]
arriving during the golden hour of this
list is the Twilight Zone this Anthology
series was created and hosted by Rod
Serling and ran for Five Seasons from
October of 1959 to June of 1964 on CBS
each episode had a standalone story with
unusual or disturbing events happening
to the characters an experience known as
entering the Twilight Zone and the
episodes which would bring in elements
of fantasy and horror at times would
most often end with a moral and perhaps
a surprise ending to go along with it
The Twilight Zone had both up and coming
and established Stars featured
throughout its run names like Carol
Burnett Robert Duvall Ron Howard chorus
Leachman Robert Redford and yes William
Shatner to name a very few the series
won two Emmys for outstanding writing
and is commonly referred to as one of
the greatest series ever period it's
appeared on the best of all time lists
throughout the years with Outlets like
TV guide and rolling stone contributing
and in 2013 The Writer's Guild of
America ranked it as the third best
written TV series ever
Mr Chambers don't get on that ship the
rest of the book to serve men
it's a cookbook
[Music]
after it was canceled Creator Rod
Serling sold his rights to the show to
CBS for a modest price little did he
know that the Twilight Zone was about to
enter the syndication uh Zone where it
continues to thrive to this very day
with no royalties going to the Creator
or the estate the series has been
rebooted a number of times including
three seasons in the mid 80s one season
in 2002 and the Jordan Peele hosted and
produced version that launched in 2019
and ran for two seasons but it seems in
this case it's hard to beat the original
a show that according to the critics
consensus from the 100 certified fresh
first season pushed the boundaries of
what a show can be
Firefly you and Zoe have been in plenty
of situations like this before right
many a Time nearly a time you and Zoe
unless we know who it was took us
together
tricky
Mal she's my wife huh what gives you the
right to put her in a dangerous
situation like this and finally shining
bright in this last spot on the list is
the fox series Firefly created by Joss
Whedon five years after he brought us
the popular show Buffy the Vampire
Slayer Firefly lasted for just one
certified fresh season the space Western
takes place a few hundred years in the
future and follows Nathan Fillion as the
captain of renegade crew that includes
Alan Tudyk Gina Torres and Morena
Baccarin as they embark on Galactic
missions for profit we didn't actually
plan for this series to run seven
seasons But ultimately Fox thought that
it was too dark and pulled the plug
after just one outing however the story
was continued in the 2005 film serenity
with Whedon and the main cast all
returning which was a hit with fans and
critics coming in certified fresh
um I must see the benefit in getting
involved in strangers troubles without
an upfront price negotiated these people
need assistance the benefit wouldn't
necessarily be for you that's what I'm
saying No One's Gonna force you to go
Jane as has been stated this job is
strictly speculative good don't know
these folks don't much care to they're
hoarse I'm in Firefly did win an Emmy
for special effects in its only season
and the franchise has continued on in
comic book form and even a role-playing
game I feel a game night coming on this
weekend the series also lives in DVD
form and on streaming where the episodes
are presented in chronological order
unlike the original run on Fox what the
heck really it has since become one of
those shows that always ends up on those
canceled too soon listicles where the
critics consensus that says Firefly
earns its audience's adoration with the
help of Nathan Fillion's dry delivery a
detailed fantasy world and compelling
story lines all right we did it thanks
for checking out our list of the best
Sci-Fi TV of all time if you have
thoughts on what else could or should
have been on this list go ahead and just
beam them up to us or stay right here at
Rotten Tomatoes until then it's time to
climb into a black hole and watch a
bunch of Sci-Fi TV episodes probably
about black holes It's So Meta thanks
for tuning in to RT Essentials I'm Mark
Ellis and remember the truth is out
there
[Applause]
[Music]